this week we will use the concepts of
momentum and energy to examine an
application of great importance
collisions a collision is an event where
two or more objects exert forces on each
other over a short time interval and
where the interaction forces dominate
over any external forces common examples
are collisions involving projectiles
collisions of motor vehicles collisions
and sports and collisions between atomic
or subatomic particles it is worth
noting that the colliding objects need
not actually touch each other in the
collision as long as the interaction
force does not require a contact for
example two positively charged protons
shot towards each other will repel each
other due to the Coulomb electric force
their interaction can be treated as a
collision even if they never actually
touch we will see that momentum is
always conserved in a collision as long
as external forces can be entirely
neglected
however energy is not necessarily
conserved this leads to the decision
between elastic collisions where energy
is conserved and inelastic collisions
where energy is not conserved
we will also derive a simple but
powerful principle in the case of
elastic collisions in one dimension that
the relative velocity of one particle
with respect to the other is simply
reversed by the collision